There are three attributes
which work with aria-live to
fine tune what is communicated to
the user when the live region changes.
Aria-atomic indicates whether the entire
region should be considered as a whole
when communicating updates.
For example, if we couldn't use a date
input, we might want to create a date
widget consisting of a stepper for
each of day, month, and year.
With aria-live=polite and
aria-atomic=true on
the containment node.
If the user used the month stepper
to change the month value alone,
the full contents of the date
widget would be read out.
The values for aria-atomic may be true
or false, with false being the default.
This means that you don't
need to explicitly specify
when aria-atomic is false.
Aria-relevant indicates what types of
changes should be presented to the user.
There are three distinct options
which may be used separately or
as a token list.
Additions, removals, and text.
An aria-relevant value of additions
means that any element being added
to the live region is significant.
For example, appending a span to
our log of chat messages would mean that
the span would be announced to the user.
Assuming that aria-atomic was false.
An aria relevant value of text implies
that text content being added to
any descendant node is
relevant regardless
of whether a new element
is actually added.
For example, changing the text
content of our alert bar would trigger
an announcement, even though we haven't
actually added a descendant element.
And aria-relevant value of removals
implies that removing any text or
any descendant element should
trigger an announcement.
The default value for
aria-relevant is additions text, meaning
that adding either a descendant element,
or adding text content through some
other mechanism is significant.
This is the most common situation so
it's rarely necessary to specify
aria-relevant explicitly.
There's also an all option which is
shorthand for additions removals text.
Meaning that literally any
change is significant.
Finally, aria-busy let's us
notify a specific technology
that it should temporarily
ignore changes to this element,
such as when things alerting say
after a temporary connectivity lapse.
Once everything is back in place,
aria-busy should be set to false.